well thanks very much for inviting me
I've been giving talks at this series
over probably the last 20 years and it's
always fun to come back the topic today
is human centered methods for improving
API usability so what our API is in this
context API sir stand for application
programming interfaces and by API we are
trying to use a very general term to
mean things like software libraries
toolkits frameworks SDK software
development kits and nowadays we also
are including things that are often
called middleware or web services and we
also want to include internal API so if
you're on a large software project you
will be using lower level features which
are usually exposed to you as an API the
key motivation for an API is so that you
can have some software resources that
you don't have to personally write that
you can reuse from others api's are
surprisingly important and valuable I
didn't realize this when we started but
there are thousands of api's just for
the web there's a site called
programmable web comm which lists over
17,000 api is with like a hundred new
ones appearing every month there's a
consulting company called Apogee that
says 77% of companies rate their api's
is a really important part of their
business model and in fact the market
for API web middleware and this is just
for the web was 5.5 billion dollars in
another way of recognizing the
importance of API is I was just visiting
Amazon and they mentioned to me that if
you go to their financial statements
most people think of Amazon as a market
income as a store in fact the store the
Amazon store lost a hundred and seventy
four million dollars in the last six
months but AWS which is their cloud
platform made 1.8 billion dollars so
really Amazon is a web services company
that happens to have a little store as a
side business and and other companies
are starting to recognize that this is a
key part of their potential business
part of the evidence of that is Google
actually bought the Apogee consulting
company for six hundred and twenty five
million dollars last year so why should
we use human centered methods for api's
well somewhat controversial my group
thinks that we can treat programmers as
if they're humans and therefore we can
use techniques that we have as an HCI
community established over the last
twenty thirty years as successful ways
of understanding people of making things
that work better for people and
evaluating what what the people who are
developers are actually experiencing and
we call this developer experience DX or
dev X as kind of an analogy with UX
which everybody understands as an
important thing to start optimizing and
api's actually have the word interface
in them and in fact they are the user
interface between this body of code and
the programmers who are trying to use it
so we can think about how to deal with
that I like this definition of
programming if you think of it
programming is basically the human
activity of translating a task that you
have in your head that you're trying to
get the computer to do into a
representation that the computer can
understand and our claim is that the
closer this the smaller this
transformation is the closer the mapping
the better off you'll be and other
people have called this similar things
so in HCI we always say if the user
interface doesn't work for the people it
doesn't actually work even if it doesn't
have any bugs you can say the same thing
about api's even if the functionality
matches what people expect if it doesn't
actually operate as people want then you
can't then you should not count it as
working there's been
number of reported examples where the
incorrect use of ap is where people
misunderstood how to use an API and used
it incorrectly resulted in bugs and even
really significant security holes in
software as I mentioned API sorting our
big business and it's starting to be
recognized that the usability of the API
or key influencers of whether people are
going to use your API is or not
and so this translates into millions or
billions of dollars for certain
companies and so API is usability
actually is an important business asset
business advantage another thing that's
important to recognize is that people
don't just use one API they're bound to
be using multiple API s and they have to
work together and finally even if you
don't have this really dramatic mistake
in the usability of your API it can
still be a pain andrew mcbean from
Google wrote this article where he
talked about how people can have death
from a thousand paper cuts that the just
annoyance after annoyance in their api's
eventually give makes them so sick of it
that they give up and try something else
HCI human-centered methods is actually a
quite a broad category most people think
of human centered methods as just
usability evaluations or a bee studies
but in fact in the HCI master's program
at CMU we teach all these methods plus
many more and they help you answer a
wide variety of different questions you
might have about people and we found
that virtually all of these can be
applied to api's in fact we've done
we've applied these methods across the
entire lifecycle of an api so at the
early stage where you're trying to
envision or plan we've used techniques
such as contextual inquiries and
interviews and surveys lab studies
something called data mining where you
take a big repository of software and
look through it to see what kind of
patterns you can find and all of these
help you understand what the
problems are at design time we have a
variety of methods to help you design
your API is after you figured out what
they should be doing and this includes a
natural programming process that we
invented to my lab we also use graphic
and interaction design as well as paper
prototyping standard HCI methods that
most people wouldn't imagine you can
apply to api's in fact work perfectly
well then you you know go ahead and
implementers api's and then you need to
evaluate them and we again use fairly
conventional HCI methods heuristic
analysis cognitive dimensions we do
usability evaluations and sometimes we
even do a versus B studies of the api's
themselves we haven't used these in my
lab but in andrew mcvane at google has
reported that they key techniques that
they use our automatic analyses so they
have tools that will automatically run
through an api and find certain problems
in analogy with the lint tool for c and
they also make heavy use of peer reviews
or design reviews or code reviews to
look at the api s-- and then finally
after release there are lots of
different mechanisms you can use log
analysis error reports feedback from
users and so forth so I mentioned that
we invented the what we call the natural
programming elicitation technique in my
lab this was quite a long time ago we
started doing this and it's basically an
idea to try and understand how your api
users are thinking about the problem
you're trying to provide an API for and
so what we're going for is what are
people's mental models what are people's
vocabulary how do they talk about this
particular design and we tend to use
blank paper tests where you just give
people a piece of paper and say imagine
you had an API for X what would you how
would you want to use it what would be
some of the objects classes methods and
so forth the trick is to figure out a
way of prompting for this without giving
away the answers
so if we say you know what would be a
good object for sending mail people will
say send mail and then you really
haven't learned anything because they
just used the words you just told them
to use so it's really tricky to come up
with ways of asking the questions they
don't give away the answers and that's
kind of a lot of the interesting
research around this method but we have
done things like understanding the API
architecture trying to understand the
vocabulary people want to use and also
which methods go in which classes so I
have a much larger scale project called
the natural programming project that
we've we've had this name since around
99 1995 but I've actually been working
as James mentioned in the area of making
programming better since as far back as
78 so the goal in general of the natural
programming project is to make
programming easier and the way we try to
do that is by making it more natural and
we don't mean natural like natural
language so we're not programming in
English or French instead we're trying
to understand how people think about it
and make it closer to that and we
obviously have to do studies to
understand how people are thinking about
it we use these studies to guide design
and we create new languages new tools
and again new API is and then we iterate
iteratively evaluate and refine these
and we target three classes of
programmers
there's expert programmers which is most
of our work we also to some extent look
at novice programmers which we define as
people who are trying to become expert
programmers so people who are in school
for example and separately there's a
group we call end-user programmers and
these are people who one colloquial way
of thinking about it or people who
program because they have to and not
because they want to
so most computer scientists enjoy
programming that's why they went into it
software engineers and so forth and they
program because they want to but there
turns out to be a really large number of
people in fact in a survey that we did
way back in 2005 and Chris cavite
actually updated the survey just this
year it's pretty consistent that
as many as 13 million people say they do
programming at work even though only 3
million of them are trained as
professional programmers so there are
lots of different jobs that involve
doing some kind of programming for
example you know writing web pages you
might write some JavaScript doing
spreadsheets you might have to program
doing database accesses doing data
analysis all sorts of different kind of
tasks require you to do programming and
so there are lots of people who do this
as part of their job not necessarily
because they want to and of course
they're scientists and engineers as well
and so one of the key points of this is
that if you're designing api's or any
other kind of tool for programmers it's
going to be used by many people who
don't necessarily have a software
engineering background and so you really
need to think about how other kinds of
people are going to be approaching the
tests that you have available for them
another way I like to describe this as
as a gentle slope system and so this is
a kind of a characterization I've been
using for many years the vertical axis
is how hard it is to do something and
the horizontal axis is how much you can
do and so thinking of Java it's pretty
hard to get started so the y-intercept
is quite high there's a lot to learn if
you want to be a Java programmer but you
can't do Mary very much with Java until
you start learning api's and so that's
why there's this wall here that after
you learn Java and you're really good at
object-oriented programming that's not
enough you have to learn how do you
swing and the listener pattern and all
sorts of special other things one needs
to know to use swing effectively or the
networking package and have to learn
sockets and all these other kinds of
things you have to learn to learn its
API s so that has a very high ceiling
you can do anything you want in Java but
maybe we'd like to have a lower
threshold so people can get started
easier so the web is a good example of
something with a lower threshold you can
use Dreamweaver or templates from
different manufacturers or WordPress or
whatever to get started and you can go
along pretty well and then all of a
sudden you realize you need to learn CSS
and HTML and that's
Waal that you'd have to overcome and
then after that you want to make your
page dynamic or do some data checking
and you have to learn JavaScript which
doesn't help very much until you learn a
million libraries on the client-side and
all the JavaScript libraries but then
you want a database and so you have to
learn server-side stuff and we show that
line crossing the Java line because not
only do you have to know how to do this
stuff but you have to know how to
coordinate these five or six different
languages together this is machine
learning
same kind of thing that there's a
million little libraries you have to
learn and have to figure out how to get
them to all work together and it's
always a lot of fun to put your own
systems on this chart and see where you
think they fall with respect to the
other ones but none of these are close
to the ideal which we draw like this
basically the idea is that no matter
where you are you can get started right
away there's not a big barrier to
getting started with this API and
everything you want to do that's more
sophisticated only requires a little
increment of learning and so you don't
get these barriers these big walls you
get this nice gentle slope all the way
through and you can keep going and do as
much as you want
so this graph applies to API is it
applies to programming languages kind of
any kind of tool that lets you do
sophisticated development and the nice
thing about this goal is that I've been
using this chart for years and we you
know don't really have much hope of
actually achieving this goal so this
means I don't have to worry about
retiring I can just keep plugging at
this forever and so can my students so
you know there's plenty of room between
where we are and where we want to go to
foster lots of interesting research
approaches so our study of api's in
particular started with Jeff styluses
PhD thesis where he graduated in 2009
he's now a lead API designer at IBM and
he interned at the API usability group
at Microsoft in the visual studio group
with Stephen Clark who kind of invented
this area of API usability and his
thesis was Jeff's thesis was a lot about
which programming patterns turned out to
be the most problematic and most usable
and we looked at learnability
error rates preferences and so forth we
studied four different three different
patterns and also collaborated with s AP
and then recently Google has funded us
to do some following research which I'll
tell you about as well so the Jeff's
first study he called the required
constructor pattern or the creeps at
call pattern and so this is the
difference between being able to create
an empty object so here we're creating a
foo which is empty and then we're
filling it in later so this is the
create set call pattern and that's as
opposed to having a required constructor
so in this case when you create a fool
you have to provide all the data that
foo needs and then you're not allowed to
change it afterwards or maybe you are
allowed to change it but typically you
wouldn't so if you know anything about
Java then a string class is immutable in
Java there's no way to change a string
after you've created one whereas most of
the other classes are immutable and you
can whoops
you can create empty ones and fill them
in so it turns out in our study that
everyone preferred the top one the
create set call pattern and it seemed to
be that it fostered exploration and
fostered learning better because people
could learn all about foo without having
to get distracted and learning about bar
first but on the other hand the security
researchers were very worried about this
because the immutability pattern the
second pattern is actually considered
much more secure and much better for
threading if you imagine you have
multiple threads if you have an
immutable object it's perfectly fine to
share them amongst the threads because
nobody's going to mock them up for
anybody else and so this is a better
approach for security and so recently we
had a follow-on research where we showed
that if you really wanted immutable
objects there was a effective way of
doing that which we presented at the
software engineering conference last
but it was a language design not an API
so I'm not going to talk about it
anymore probably the most famous study
that we did was on what's called the
factory pattern so normally when in
object-oriented programming when you
want a new object you say new object so
widget W equals new widget in the
factory pattern you're not allowed to do
that
you're required to go off and find this
other thing called the factory and ask
it for widget so in this case you say F
dot create me a widget and so this means
that when you're trying to do stuff with
widgets you also have to somehow figure
out that you need this other class as
well very common pattern it's used a lot
in Java and.net and SCP and if you go to
books they actually recommend using this
pattern in contrast we found it to be
really problematic that programmers
found it very hard to use nobody ever
expected it to be there and when it was
there it had a measurable impact on
performance it was two to five times
slower and more problematic to figure
out how to use another study we did was
on object place method placement so in
any real API you're going to have
multiple classes that are required
multiple different groups of
functionality and you have to figure out
it's a program or how to put them
together and that is often very
difficult so here's an example in Java
in the male program there's two classes
that coordinate together one's called
the transport class and the other is
called the message class and you as an
API designer have to pick one to put the
send method on so which one would you
pick
right so usually at this point I asked
the class or the audience so how many
people think it would be a better design
to put the send on the transport class
okay four or five and how many people
think it'd be a better design to have
the send on the message class nobody two
or three and all the other people who
didn't vote well if you were an API
designer you're really not allowed to
abstain right you have to make a
decision this is not one of those things
where you can just say well I don't care
I'm not going to put it anywhere right
because you need a send method
you can't send your mail so you know you
have to really make a choice and so it
turns out in Java it was put on the
transport method but everybody expected
it to be on the send on the message
method everyone expected to be able to
take your email message and send it
somewhere because that's kind of how you
talk about it and the fact that it was
in the wrong place actually was very
confusing to people and they would go to
the message class and they couldn't find
the send method anywhere so now they
were really confused about how they
should go about sending emails and it
turns out that this has a really
significant impact on people's
performance between 2 and 11 times
slower as well as making it much harder
to know what to do another interesting
observation is that the naming of
classes is often very problematic so in
Java if you want to do something to the
disk you might think in your head that
you want to deal with files and if you
go and search the class hierarchy for a
file you'll discover it's an abstract
class that you can't actually use right
it's an interface or whatever and so
it'll say oh you can't use me but I have
you know subclasses pick one of those
all right so that's not particularly
helpful you have to know that you need
to use a stream buffer which is not
anybody's first guests of the name of
the thing you want to use so this kind
of object-oriented design where you put
this the name everyone thinks of that
the top seems to make perfect sense from
kind of an object hierarchy point of
view but from a usability point of view
is really a nightmare so we leveraged
all of this research into a really
fruitful multi-year collaboration with a
software company called
sa P which is based in Germany it's
actually one of the largest software
companies in the world that nobody's
heard of because they all will they only
do back-end software so software that
runs big corporations like universities
and
yep so this is so they definitely they
definitely are problems with s AP
software and somehow they needed us to
tell them what the problem was here so
this was back in the days before rest
everyone was using Web Services called
soap which stood for a simple object
something protocol it wasn't simple at
all which is why no one uses it anymore
and this is their actual names of some
of the methods and their Web Services it
turns out in Java there's a limit of 255
characters on Rd names and they'd run
into that limit and this is looking at
their API is in an IDE and you'll notice
the first six look identical in fact
they're differences we over here
somewhere and if you hover over them you
can see that it actually shows you less
of the name when you hover over them and
there's no horizontal scrollbar on this
thing so you really just are guessing
there's no way to know which one you're
getting until you get it and even when
you do get it it's really hard to know
which one you've gotten because then the
differences are all in the middle of
these long names and so anyway somehow
they needed us to tell them that was a
problem their documentation was also
problematic so we did a map of all the
different parts of their documentation
and what you had to do to navigate from
the top down to finding the actual name
of an operation that you wanted and this
shows some of the paths of some of our
users went and there were lots of cycles
and dead ends and misleading parts of
the documentation one interesting
observation is that at some point the
documentation changed color from orange
to blue and everybody gave up
immediately and figured they had left
the documentation because of this design
color change and you know in fact if
they pushed through they would have
gotten back to orange and would have
been able to find it another thing that
we noticed is it's really important in
this situation to understand the domain
right so this was for business
and you notice that all the
documentation has these things like SCM
and SRM and if you're a business person
these make a lot of sense if you've not
you don't know what these acronyms stand
for it turned out that non business
people had no hope of not navigating
this documentation and finding anything
appropriate so what would you do with
this information if you know that ap is
are problematic ideally you would change
them but you know we as researchers are
not gonna have much luck changing the
java api s-- and also as an API designer
you may have other things that you're
trying to optimize not necessarily
entirely focusing on usability it may
have to be backwards compatible it may
have to have higher performance and
therefore we can think about tools so
how can you use tools to fix some of
these problems with the api s-- and so
we built these seven tools all of which
have wonderful gemstone names and
acronyms that you'll see and that help
you with the with these kinds of
problems so the first one is micah
making interfaces clear and accessible
and this was right at the beginning of
the era where people recognize that
Google was the super best way of finding
documentation and so whenever anybody
had a programming problem they would
type it into Google and find the
appropriate examples and documentation
and this was right at the beginning
where that was starting to be done and
we recognized that this was kind of a
totally new paradigm of ways of have
documentation and maybe we could make it
even better
so what micah does is it takes the
Google results and processes it to
provide more information so it provides
a list of all the keywords that it finds
in the return values and you can hover
over the different keywords and find
which ones describe it it put this
little icon near the results that had
code examples because everybody loves
code examples and many of these don't
have them and so you know this way you
can augment the results that it gives
back to make them more useful from
programmers
and this obviously is a ubiquitous kind
of thing that's done now but we were
really the first people to show it and
happy to say we recently won an award
this was just two weeks ago and here's
Jeff and me winning this award in
October for this paper is the most
influential paper and Jeff is getting
great tool that's happens to students
they get older too so jadeite is another
the next tool we built Java API
documentation with extra information
tacked on for emphasis jadeite takes the
Javadoc and tries to make it more useful
using some of this kind of knowledge so
one of the things it does is to make the
names of the classes bigger based on how
often they are used and so this will
guide people to using the right classes
to start with because there's just
otherwise a really long list
remember the problem about where the
send method should be so this green
thing is what we call a place holder
that in the message class you can put
this pretend version of send which says
oh there really is no send here go off
to this other place and find it so the
idea is to you know help people exactly
where they need the help without trying
to put it somewhere else that it doesn't
actually exist and we also scoured the
web for examples of how to use the class
and provided those and also showed which
other classes tend to be used together
so remember you need to use a transport
class with the message class and so we
tell people about that so wouldn't it be
nice to have that information directly
in the IDE and the tool that you're
using for editing your code and so
that's what Cal site does the idea here
is that we just bring all that
information into Eclipse so while you're
everybody's favorite way of doing coding
or exploring an API is by typing dot and
looking at the pop-up autocompletes and
so we wanted to add more information
into that popup menu and so that's what
Cal site does
in this case in a typical if you ever
tried popping up the autocomplete menu
after an equal sign you'll discover not
much happens it's really pretty useless
and that's why it doesn't come up by
default you know it only comes up by
default after a dot but you can pop it
up anywhere you want and you can see
what it will tell you we augmented that
menu with a lot of extra information
like how to use sockets to get one of
these objects to exist how to use the
factory pattern and it brings in a lot
of the other information into the pop-up
menus as well so if you go to the
message class and pop up the menu send
will be there even though it doesn't
really exist and it'll tell you how to
go off and find the real code so that
jadeite and calcite were based on
scouring the web for examples and that
obviously works really well for Java but
it won't work for most other tools that
are poorly you know that aren't widely
use or which aren't comprehensive and so
de site is another kind of boring Rock
but it was an interesting system for
design annotations for complementing
interfaces targeting effectiveness was
by a visitor who came over and the idea
of here is to use the Java annotation
mechanism which is surprisingly flexible
and in Java annotations you can add an @
sign and then put kind of anything you
want and then you can run processors at
compile time that will check things and
generate data and so forth so the idea
of de site is you annotate things like
factory patterns or helper functions and
then it will generate a plug-in for you
that can then be used in your editor
IntelliJ or Eclipse or whatever in order
to help you in the same way as calcite
but it also supported other things like
helper methods object builders static
factories decorators composite classes
so there's a bunch of other patterns
that are hard to detect by scouring the
web but which the developer knows
they're doing and so this makes it a lot
easier
I had a visitor from Germany who had a
system in German called or CLIs which is
German for you clays which is another
gemstone and he luckily made us in
English acronym or we wouldn't be able
to tell you what it was and the idea of
this is to deal with the common case
that programmers like to copy and paste
from examples and so what or close does
is it helps keep track of where you
copied the code from and how it should
automatically adapt it from the source
to the destination so it fits in better
with your destination and so it can do
some static analysis in order to help
you update the code to better fit
graphite is a cute little plugin that's
to help you with constants literal
constants it turns out there a lot of
special constants you need to do in
languages like if you want to color
value what kind of colors should use and
this will basically pop up a color wheel
and let you pick the color like you
would in a graphics editor but instead
it'll just pop in the into the code and
it also worked for regular expressions
then finally appetite is associative
perusing of api's that identifies
targets easily the idea of this is to
kind of look at the documentation
sideways it's kind of a new way of
looking at documentation by association
and the goal of appetite is that maybe
you have a question which classes have a
read method and so you just click on
read and that shows you all the classes
that have a read methods sorted by
popularity so the most popular messages
are post master classes are bigger it's
also answers the question what other
methods are typically used with read and
they appear here or which actions do
read usually associated with and so
forth and so by clicking on things in
one column you get a bunch of
associations of different types in the
second column and then you can keep
going as far as you want and this will
you know provide information that's
associated with each of the actions
so that's kind of where we were and then
recently former a suit a formers a
former student who I was on their thesis
committee went to Google and said we
really care about API usability wouldn't
you like to start a new project studying
modern API modern web service API since
so that's kind of fun and so the first
two projects we did were to compare API
style guides and interview a bunch of
API designers so this style guidelines
we just presented Monday at the plateau
conference in Vancouver and the idea of
this is that a surprisingly large number
of companies will publish guidelines so
you've probably heard of Java guidelines
or the Apple style guidelines so these
are style guides for user interfaces but
they're also style guidelines for api's
and they're surprisingly large number of
them we found 40 of them fairly quickly
and 32 of those were about these rest
api is the modern style of providing web
services and so we were wondering you
know what what people are saying about
REST API is and how much they agreed in
disagree so these are the 32 ones that
we analyzed in depth in alphabetical
order in the paper that has a fewer the
full URLs of all of them if you want to
see more detail the kind of some of the
big names are there Amazon Google IBM
Microsoft notable missing our Facebook
and some of the other big API companies
we found some of these in a website
called API style book comm other ones we
just found with Google search it's also
interesting to see the giant differences
in the size of these so the Google API
is are trying to be quite comprehensive
and explain kind of all of the things
you're supposed to do and not do as a
Google API designer whereas other ones
that are particularly short like rest
cheat sheet are intended to be kind of
read from cover
cover and just give you a sense of what
sort of things you should be thinking
about we looked at all the things that
all the guidelines have said and
collected their recommendations into
categories and so these are the
categories of guidelines that we found
and they're sorted here by the number of
different guidelines sets that mention
that particular category of problem so
30 of the 32 guideline sets mentioned
status codes so the paper talks about
most of these but here I'm just going to
talk about a few that we found
particularly interesting so all of the
api's have to you know have to deal with
versioning you know you have a new
version and it works slightly
differently how do you tell API users
what the version is refere these
differed significantly across the
different guideline sets some have the
typical three level versioning like two
point four point one where the last one
was either a patch or a draft number
some just said to use two one just said
to have a single number and one said
don't use numbers at all use dates
instead they also had different
locations where they wanted you to put
the version eleven of them said it
should be in the URL like here
alais eight of them said it should be in
HTTP header and not in the URL number
URL at all and then one said you should
put part of it in the URL and the other
part should be in the parameter or the
body of the message so surprising
amounts of differences they're backwards
compatibility is really important so
when you have an API and you need to
change it should the change be done in a
way that code it's using this API will
not break that's obviously better some
of the guidelines mentioned what it
means to be backwards compatible what it
means to be a breaking change or a non
breaking change and a number of them
mentioned posts tells law which is kind
of a description of the web and web
browsers how they will try and be
generous and accept kind of anything and
try to deal with it
liberal and what you accept and
conservative and what you send out so
this is a good idea for api's as well
naming was interesting so the Google API
has very specific recommendations for
particular words to use for particular
kinds of things whereas virtually none
of the other API is picked particular
words although a lot of them had
something to say about parts of speech
so use nouns for this kind of thing and
use verbs for this other kind of thing
because obviously in English you can mix
those up and that gets to be confusing
so they said you know always use nouns
for object names or something like that
and then there's a lot of differences in
how to what kind of case to use like
upper case lower case camel case I think
we've all seen a lot in various kinds of
code that's recommended by some people
as opposed to snake case a fun name and
that's where you use underscores and
then for URLs where you you're allowed
to use hyphens apparently that's called
kebab case like a shish kebab through
the middle I never heard that but that's
fun too so you can use kebab case ER or
snake case and surprisingly lack of
consistency they these recommendations
were all over the place with the
different guideline sets everybody said
documentation is good no surprise there
and everybody is in favor of having good
documentation but there was controversy
about whether the documentation should
be automatically generated or not
so web service API is are basically
about the information sent over the
Internet but the consumers are in
typically a wide variety of languages so
many api's are have to be implemented in
JavaScript and maybe in regular Java
maybe in Python maybe in C C++ if you
talking about server-side then again
there's a whole nother collection of
languages dart rust go so some of these
some of the companies have to have the
same API and
for ten or fifteen different languages
and that can be really difficult to
manually create those and so there are
lots of tools that automatically will
create your libraries and then create
the documentation that goes with it and
so some of the guideline sets were in
favor of doing that to make sure that
they're consistent on the other hand
that documentation is known to be
problematic so some of the documentation
some of the guideline sets recommended
against doing it automatically and one
said well do both have it automatically
generated and then manually fix it which
kind of defeats the whole purpose and
one tool that's starting to be popular
is called swagger which is a public tool
that people are starting to use it's
also called open API so that was fun
but we really want to learn more about
why people were making these
recommendations and what designers were
thinking about and so we ran an
interview study so far with 14 API
designers across four companies I'm not
allowed to tell you who they are because
that was confidential we promised them
confidentiality but it was pretty
extensive interviews with each one one
and a half to two hours each and we were
able to get quite experienced API
designers so a mean of 9.1 years of
designing api's ranging from 1 to 18 and
they were also obviously really
experienced programmers as well a mean
of 16 years up to 28 years of
programming and then we had a fun little
workshop it was kind of a meeting like
this where we got to discuss API design
with 50 different designers at the same
time and we are in the process of trying
to recruit a few more to interview and
these people represented API is in a
wide variety of situations old fashion
in some sense C++ API is Java Dart
c-sharp and of course many of the modern
REST API is as well and some were for
internal use and most of them were
external or externally visible we asked
people what the size of their API was
and they found this very hard to answer
how do you measure the size of something
like this and typically the answer they
would come up with is how many methods
they had so 20 to 300 methods but
another answer is how many users they
had so the kind of minimum was a
hundreds of users and the maximum was
millions of programmers using their API
so obviously quite a significant impact
we asked them what it meant to be a high
quality API and the number one answer
was simplicity typically meaning easy to
learn only does one thing does it very
clearly people can figure out how to use
it without reading the documentation
very much the number one goal to have a
really high quality API the second thing
people mentioned which kind of goes
along with it is matching the users
needs which everyone reported was hard
to identify hard to figure out exactly
what people wanted this API to do and
how they wanted to express it so that
was their kind of number one thing that
they had difficulty finding out that
would help them with their jobs they all
recognized that consistency was a key
goal key problem that they had to solve
and hence this was driving a lot of the
guideline sets because that is a big way
of achieving consistency we asked them
what would be an example of a good API
and in terms of a conventional Java
style API people mentioned guava is the
exemplar of high quality API and then
for web services typically people said
stripe which is a financial processing
API was held out as being high quality
well documented
easy to understand and simple and
interesting ly we asked people how did
they learn to do API design and
virtually nobody had any training in
this at all that nothing that anybody
learned at university even the ones who
had PhDs in software engineering nothing
they learned was relevant to the task of
API design that was a little
discouraging the
keyways they learned was on the job so
more senior people said oh yeah we just
tried a bunch of things and we learned
what didn't work and learn from our
mistakes learned what people complained
about and what ended up being hard to
maintain more junior people said they
were fortunate to have senior people
around to learn from to apprentice with
many of the companies use design reviews
as I'll mentioned in a minute and they
found that also very illuminating when
senior people came and looked at their
designs and told them and gave them
feedback about it only one of all the
people we talked to said that anything
that was even mentioned in class was
useful and he happened to have a
professor that mentioned API design and
taught a few things about it in one
lecture of a software engineering class
but other than that nothing anybody
learned was relevant even though this is
a quite a large number of people are
involved in this kind of task as part of
their work in in companies and we asked
them is there some book or blog or you
know discussion forum where you
typically look for good information and
nobody really said anything and
certainly there wasn't any consistency
amongst different people so we were
wondering how people organize their API
design what was the process that they
used and it was quite informal you would
imagine something as high impact as
api's might have a very strict or formal
process we did not find that many people
mentioned having design reviews so in
companies it seems like code reviews are
a key quality a key way that they try
and insert code quality everything
that's released is required to go
through a code review and similarly the
api's had a design review sometimes it
was the same review that the people
doing the code review would also
consider the API design as part of their
review
they had occasionally did these kind of
reviews of early designs but usually it
was the finished implementation they as
I mentioned they were
these guidelines so you can imagine that
the people who worked at the companies
that had guidelines found those
guidelines particularly useful as a way
of trying to follow but they also
reported that occasionally they will we
they didn't actually admit this but
other people said that they weren't
really following the guidelines and so
that was sometimes a problem but besides
that there was really no standard
process that there really was quite a
divergence of the kinds of things that
people would do and the process they'd
use I thought it was really interesting
that you know if you think about regular
gooeys at this point no major company is
going to let their programmers design a
user interface anymore that they have UX
specialists that do that kind of thing
this was not the case for api's the leaf
engineers the kind of lowest level
engineers were in fact empowered with
making significant design decisions
about the api's there's some companies
that had product managers that would
sometimes get involved and one company
mentioned the chief architect which
would deal with kind of architectural
issues but they still were many
decisions that a leaf engineer would get
to decide for themselves and a little
bit sad to notice there to identify that
nobody had ever done or even heard of
doing a usability evaluation of the API
before it was released they pretty much
relied on beta releases and so they
release it and beta users would give
them feedback on the usability of their
API so and that was kind of it after
they did the guidelines and the code
reviews and also the documentation was
typically written by the engineers
themselves and some high-impact api's
did have tech writers helping but
generally it was the engineers
themselves the key issue key problem
that people mentioned was backwards
compatibility they were always really
worried about this because API is with a
millions of programmers out there you
know if you change something people are
going to be angry at you and an
interesting piece of feedback was that
people work
old-fashioned languages like C++ said
that pretty much anything they did was a
breaking change that there's no such
thing as a non-breaking change in C++
because people have visibility kind of
in any everything and there's really no
information hiding and something like
C++ but we heard all sorts of stories
about how you know people had unit tests
that checked for the actual string of
the error message and so when they
change the error message as a result of
a refactoring than people's tests broke
our the lying number in the code that
was exposed as part of the debugging
message was being used by people and so
basically there was no that nothing that
people could do that was a non-breaking
change and so that was really annoying
one group of people had at there had the
availability for the entire code base of
the company and they were able to change
api's internal api's and then themselves
be able to change all the code that used
the API so they were less worried about
API changes because they could actually
themselves API designers could be
responsible for updating all the code
that uses it that sounds kind of scary
because they're actually changing code
they have no idea what it does that uses
their API but it was related to me that
it's less problematic than you think
because they had good unit tests and so
the claim was that the API designer
could change the code recompile it run
all the unit tests and if it all passed
then they were golden and they didn't
have to involve the actual authors of
that part of the code that still seems a
little worrisome to me what are the
other challenges and these are some of
the things that we're working on for
future research is what are the best
design patterns for api's do we have any
way of talking about good things and bad
things especially for web api's what are
the right ways to go how do we help
people coordinate multiple api's there's
really been virtually no research on
what you can do in terms of
documentation or tooling to help people
with putting api's together
and do we need to invent some new
evaluation mechanisms at lunch we were
talking about you know how do you
evaluate if this new version of your API
is actually better or not or is my API
better than your API how would you go
about evaluating that and finally if
you're a company what are the best
practices in API design if you wanted to
say that you are following best
practices what would that even be like
so if you're interested in this area of
API usability we wrote a nice overview
article of what we've done last summer
that's the C ACM article kind of gives a
nice overview as I mentioned we have
this new paper that we just published on
Monday it talks about the style
guidelines and then we have lots of
other worked it on our my site on the
net natural programming site on API
usability but we also are maintaining
API usability org which tries to collect
the other a lot of resources just real
quickly I want to mention some other
research projects that I didn't talk
about what we're working on exploratory
programming to try and help data
scientists investigate things through
code we're working on a conversational
agent through programming by example so
it's fun to get back to protein for
example I mentioned the work on
immutability and michael has gone on to
work on blockchain programming and
trying to make that more usable because
that's really important these days and
then finally I have a brand new project
we just started on what we call
knowledge accelerator to try and help
with the process of gaining new
knowledge and then keeping track of it
and many of these are fun acronyms and
some of them I went over some of them I
didn't but if you like acronyms and
gemstones we have plenty of those and
there's lots more on my website
naturally all this work was done with my
students or by my students and so I have
to thank them I have thanked my funding
people mostly from the NSF but also from
a bunch of companies and then I have to
thank you for inviting me
[Applause]
my mouth is an instance of coming in the
way to phrase so we're simply ask them
to to say please use transport to send a
message in this sentence transferred his
subject verb descendant messages the
object or any metal in the order it
should be transported sent message
powder if you say please send a message
via transport all son there is no
subject and now like the transport is
now kind of looking the preposition
phrase right then you try like
alternative phrasings for the task yeah
so as I mentioned in the natural formula
cetacean method that is a key problem is
not giving away the answer in the
question
so typically we wouldn't have any
phrasing of it we would have pictures we
would have a list of functions or
functionalities that are required and
it's it's a little tricky but we
definitely are very careful to make sure
that the doesn't give away any of the
aspects of the answer that we're looking
for and they're definitely a lot of work
in that so Google has something called
their API Explorer that's kind of on the
front of their API page where you can
try out api with different
configurations and different parameters
right there on the web without having to
configure anything and they found they
did some one of the papers they wrote
was how people are using that and it's
not kind of the most obvious use is not
what you think of people actually doing
that but in fact people are using that
as documentation
because it kind of shows you what kind
of parameterizations make sense for this
API so companies are definitely thinking
about you know given that people are
doing this interactively what would be
some interesting new ways of presenting
it that's aren't just PDF documents or
web pages or whatever and then certainly
researchers have done some interesting
work in this area so Joel Brandt who's
now an Adobe his thesis oh right he
moved his nap and his thesis from was
here or Berkeley here yeah he did this
cool thing where he embedded the
examples into the editor and then you
know you got documentation and examples
all in context and that you know made it
the kind of explorations you're talking
about more integrated and so I think
there's both commercial and research
interest in given the way modern
programmers actually work how can we
reconfigure both exploration tools and
documentation to be more effective I've
seen in many cases ranging from web
toolkit organizations and others where
you have the API then there's an API
client and then some sort of packages
that thing and there's another one
potentially even on top of that and you
get these either different distractions
or at least sort of different angles on
the same question so one so clearly you
could do it you could do usability
evaluation on each of these layers try
to improve them but I wonder at what
level does it make more sense given the
human centered perspective to stop
saying you know let's fix this thing
instead say like let's consider
different kinds of users
different layers alright and even more
complicated that could you have to also
consider the tools that people are using
so I des and so forth can have a big
impact on which of those there's the
most use usable so that yeah there
definitely is this whole ecosystem of
different aspects in some sense when
people are making wrappers around your
client libraries and that's kind of a
hint that there's some problem with your
client libraries and so the companies
are definitely very interested in
evaluating why people are feeling like
they need wrappers around their client
libraries but a lot of the stuff we were
talking about like automatic generation
and you know all of that about
generating their client libraries we
definitely heard in the interviews that
like some of the designers in obscure
languages were annoyed that the
automatically generated client libraries
didn't seem very consistent with the way
their language would normally be done
because they were designed by people who
are like Java experts and so you know
they would say oh that automatically
generated client libraries are too Java
like and in my language that's really
not the right way you would think about
things so I think that's definitely a
good area for future research of how can
we make these client libraries better so
that people aren't motivated to Train
wrap them I don't remember much specific
about that the main thing is as I
mentioned already that they use that as
a signal that there were problems that
they might want to address and you know
you have to remember that most of these
especially the web api is change
quarterly sometimes and so it's
obviously a really big job for the third
parties to keep up and so they you know
that's also an issue
let's do
you said somewhere but you have and it's
order of magnitude size of the effect
that you've seen many warning systems by
yeah we're talking about it yeah we'd
get a factor of two to ten improvement
in time but you know that went from two
minutes to twenty minutes kind of thing
was really not that impactful on the
other hand the work we did with sa P in
some of our experiments it took
programmers a week to figure out how to
get three or four methods actually work
because they kept having to send emails
off to somebody and waiting for answers
because the designs were so awful that
there was really no way to figure them
out without somebody knowledgeable
telling you the answer and so in a
better design they could do that in you
know three or four minutes so that was
you know a completely different order of
magnitude then we could even imagine
testing in the lab and you know in terms
of these companies nobody would give me
any numbers but they all agreed that
they have lost sales as a result of API
usability to their competitors and so I
definitely had the sense that there were
monetary measurements that you could
imagine making but they wouldn't tell me
the answers to that were the monetary
impact of usability as they lost
customers compared to other api's that
were more usable time to code yeah
although these are obviously interlinked
the Google guys have a phrase I think
it's time to two hundred right so most
of the web messages who get error rates
you get an error message returned you
know four or five or bad I forget all
that all the code numbers right and then
eventually you'll get a successful
return
which is 200 returned from your HTTP
message and so you know all of the bad
messages were errors because they people
didn't understand how to use the API is
correctly so I don't think you can
really distinguished errors from
learning because that's kind of
fundamental noting the time but please
feel free to come up and share my
straight
[Applause]
you